Originality, honesty, and a point of view.
The 21st century Beetle still has what it takes to be a Beetle.
But with a sleek, new look...
...complimented by the power of an available 200 horsepower turbocharged engine,...
...the all new 2012 Beetle is like none before it.
Wanna take a closer look?
Of course, you do.
For only the second time in its 70 - year history,...
...Volkswagen has radically redesigned the exterior of the Beetle.
Its new design is sleeker and more masculine.
Designed for the 21st century and features great exterior details.
Plus, there's an available giant panoramic sun roof.
On the inside, it's roomier and refined.
There's an available Fender premium audio system that offers high clarity sound at high volumes.
There's also a bluetooth hands-free calling system,...
...which, on some models, will sync with your mobile device...
...and stream your music library through the car's audio system.
Somewhere along the way, the Beetle became a symbol for fun...
...and that's just something you don't wanna mess with, so VW didn't.
The all new 2012 Beetle still speaks for everyone:...
...young and old, across cultures, class, and countries worldwide.
It's just been brought up to speed for the 21st century.
You could see more for yourself at vw.com.